[Music]
hi everybody my name is Kari months and
I'm the director of engineering for the
platform infrastructure teams at HubSpot
and I'm here to tell you the tale of
going both multi-cloud and multi-region
for the first time at HubSpot in q1 of
this year there are few key lessons we
learned from this experience and the one
that I want you all to know is that it
can be done fast and the key to this is
treating your infrastructure as dynamic
as your application code your
infrastructure is code so let's start
briefly with what is HubSpot how about
as a leading CRM marketing sales and
customer experience platform we offer
sales and marketing automation software
and it helps companies attract visitors
convert leads clothes and delight
customers we focus on small and medium
businesses we offer sales
excuse me we help the small guys nurture
their customer relationships as
effectively as the big guys so this is
where our journey starts with our CEO
Brian Halligan is HubSpot CEO we were
opening an office in Berlin to
strengthen our commitment to our EU
customers and we needed to give them
better performance stronger security and
Brian wanted tighter integrations with
Adwords and G suite and on top of all
that he wanted to offer more free
services to our customers as you all may
know freemium is not free to hosts so we
manage our infrastructure costs very
efficient efficiently the million-dollar
question with any project is time we
already had a lot on her plate with a
big mysql migration and we were a big
migration into kubernetes and this added
a ton more but we knew it was important
to our customers and wanted to support
the business he told us this would be in
q1 and he had come to us in
of last year's so the timeline was very
short when he said q1 I imagined a fiery
hellscape what I wanted to say was go
after yourself but what I actually said
was we got this so I went to our
infrastructure teams I told them that we
were on the hook to support our EU
customers they came up with a few
options they said we could consider
expanding with AWS we could consider
spinning up our own data center or we
could consider a new cloud provider so
in the end we went with Google Cloud so
the rest of this tale is to show you why
that was not scary with our foundation
of tooling how we tested our biggest
fears fast and how we uncovered 11 years
of our unknown dependencies lurking in
our infrastructure to successfully ship
a new EU data center in q1 so hub spots
best kept secret our is our amazing
platform infrastructure teams these 14
teams have the mission to make our 60
other product teams as effective and
efficient as possible basically to give
them superpowers
to improve the reliability and
efficiency of our platform and to keep
the free in freemium the foundation of
all of this is that everything at
HubSpot is code have you all ever heard
the expression of pets versus cattle
referring to your servers so pets are
the ones that you baby you take care of
them because they are mission-critical
and they are irreplaceable so they can
destroy your business if they die cattle
are all identical you can shoot one in
the head and another one will take its
place at HubSpot we only have cattle no
pets so our platform supports tooling
for our marketing sales and services
customers this runs on top of a giant
automation and analytics platform that
is processing a ton of data data based
on analytics ads contacts email chat all
sorts of things processing data from all
sorts of sources on behalf
of our customers so how do we manage all
of that Big Data there are many
different types of workloads that are
neat workflows that are needed to make
it all work seamlessly together we have
focused largely on open source because
years ago the cloud was not so mature
and we needed the control to be able to
dig in and tune our data services as we
needed we wanted to be able to touch the
code it was also because of the need to
be able to control costs to keep
freemium free we actually have hundreds
of thousands of free customers so we run
our infrastructure with costs in mind
and over the years we wrote a lot of
automation software to keep our data
infrastructure running smoothly since
scale can mean many things to different
companies here I want to give you some
quick numbers to get a sense of what it
meant when we said we were going multi
cloud and multi-region so HBase is the
heart of HubSpot data our HBase clusters
are processing up to 90 million requests
per second that's nearly high and
processing nearly half a petabyte a day
Kafka is hub spots bloodstream with
Kafka we are handling around a million
requests per second elasticsearch is our
nerve system supporting nearly half a
billion documents the bane of my
existence is MySQL we actually have more
than 500 MySQL clusters and at HubSpot
they grow like mushrooms I think our
engineers can't tell the difference
between a database and a table so that
totals more than 1300 individual VMs and
we have historically had one person
managing all of them he knew them all
personally essentially he had 500 pets
and there were far too many manual
operations to tend to them all so early
last year we decided to change all of
that
which was lucky considering the decision
that we were the move we were going to
need the EU data center later in the
year we needed to orchestrate the life
cycles of those 500 clusters and at the
same time a lot of our relational style
data was too big I mean
to move a lot of that data into HBase to
be able to support the request load we
chose by tests and kubernetes to solve
this problem for us by test is an open
source clustering system to automate
horizontal scaling of MySQL and it was
created by the YouTube team we've become
very active contributors to this project
it essentially is a proxy to sequel
queries
it makes sharding very simple to support
horizontal scaling in an easy way
it also replaced our manual and ansible
plays that we use to handle things like
master/slave fail overs when machines
would fail we run by tests inside of
kubernetes we have years of experience
with maysa for orchestrating dr
containers and JVMs for running our own
applications and we were excited to find
a system to orchestrate our data stores
as easily as our applications and we
could share server resources for those
1,300 VMs instead of relying on
dedicated machines
so our kubernetes migration was already
underway when our CEO came to me
so why did we consider Google we've been
running enough
we've been running HubSpot in AWS for 10
years when Brian came to us and said we
needed to do better by our yo customers
and we needed better integrations with
Adwords and G suite we said it was time
to survey the cloud landscape so
BigTable is the basis for HBase we've
admired BigTable performance numbers for
a long time we put a lot of resources
into HBase and dreamed of a future where
Google would take care of all of those
headaches for us plus if you've ever had
a visit from the Google team or talk to
the BigTable engineers they will walk
into your conference room draw a picture
that looks exactly like this on your
wall board whiteboard drop the
microphone and just leave the room so we
were interested in knowing more we were
also interested in Google because we
were big fans of their open source we
have our own internal commitment to open
source and have published some tools
like blazar in singularity I'll tell you
about a little later
and we were already actively
contributing to by testing kubernetes
our infrastructure team was also
interested in seeing what cool things
they could do using Google's Network
offerings plus the timing was perfect
Google was coming out with a data center
in Frankfurt in q4 so the big reason we
are here I am here is to tell this tale
of the foundation of our tools and how
that helped us to move very quickly I
want to point out to you a few areas
that we needed to update to be able to
support a new cloud provider and a new
region and how this could work for you
too
so first I'll give you some details
about the components that make up our
platform so you understand what I'm
talking about so right now we are
running more than 3000 VMs in the cloud
all of our infrastructure tools
interface with our cloud providers
through a tool called Rainmaker
Rainmaker is the foundation of our
infrastructure as code approach it wraps
all of the cloud primitives like the API
is to spin up spin up and down VMs
attached disks manage storage buckets do
security group management things like
that we use puppet to keep the
configuration for all of our VMs
consistent puppet updates are managed
through github and they are deployed
like any other app in our deployment
pipeline
so the hub swap product is actually made
up of more than 6,000 micro services
jobs and tasks all running on top of
singularity in May sews singularity is
our open source app orchestration
framework that is powered by Apache
massifs we introduced singularity into
our platform a few years ago to remove
the complexity of running and deploying
workloads directly to machines it used
to be that engineers had to worry about
everything everything for their services
and tasks they would worry about
horizontally scaling those services they
would worry about whether the underlying
hardware would fit was failing so
singularity let engineers focus on what
they do best which is writing software
instead of managing infrastructure on
top of our app orchestration framework
we have a highly efficient CI CD
pipeline to make it extremely
for our engineers to build and deploy
code fast
we have over 2,000 active github repos
for all of those micro services and
tasks we have actually archived over
6,000 other repos over the years which
is because we are constantly
experimenting improvement in improving
how HubSpot runs so we wrote blaze our
our build orchestration tool we use it
to run all of we used to run all of our
builds on Jenkins but because of the
explosive growth of our repos and
branches it became too complex to manage
the UI basically turned into a hell
scape for our engineers we addressed
those pains by building blaze are around
github web hooks it automatically
detects new repos and requires no extra
configuration to know exactly what to
build blaze our runs inside of
singularity itself so last year Blizzard
did more than two and a half million
builds and this year we are on track to
run more than 4 million builds we also
wrote our own deploy tool called Orion
Orion makes it simple for our engineers
to deploy workloads into singularity
more than 10,000 times a week last year
we in fact deployed over 900,000 times
to both QA and prod and we put a heavy
investment into the user experience for
Orion because this tool is so critical
for our engineers to get their work done
it sports health checks acceptance and
acceptance tests for example we also
acknowledge that engineers do not write
perfect code so we Pro prioritize mean
time to repair making it simple to
rollback changes as well so now back to
our story on how we expanded to the EU
with Google so to start a project like
this is an important question in any
engineering leaders toolbox is how can
we keep it simple
since HubSpot is made up of thousands of
micro services and jobs making a fully
chartered version of HubSpot in such a
short amount of time would be reckless
and we were not reckless we were
confident but not reckless so we started
by narrowing the focus we
ourselves what was the most important
thing for reliability and performance
for our customers in the EU we already
have approximately 70,000 websites
fronted by CloudFlare across the globe
for fast performance but anytime data is
submitted by our customers customers it
goes back to our origin in Virginia and
if there are issues with the network or
any other issues back at the origin that
data could be lost so it's important
that we did not miss any of the
collecting any usage data so we focused
on analytics click tracking CTAs and
those sorts of collected collection
services so as I said before we have
been AWS customers for 10 years so the
next most important thing to figure out
was what did we fear about Google so we
made a list and there were in fact three
things simply could we deploy to GCP
with the network connection between AWS
and GCP be fast enough and there was
this thing the Google team told us about
called live migrations so to start the
question was could we simply deploy
services to GCP we wanted to make sure
our engineers didn't need to care about
the details of running on Google and
also about running in another region I
mentioned Rainmaker earlier as our VM
management tool
back in 2012 VM management was really
hard to do so we had created Rainmaker
to abstract away AWS console and
primitives and create one simple way to
spin up servers correctly so the thing
that we created six years ago to work
better with AWS became a key factor and
making it easy to work with Google too
so what we did was we looked at the API
calls we needed to make Google so we
could start stopped machine set up disk
configuring networking and this was just
a matter of refactoring our code to
create a second adapter the first
adapter was to handle the AWS primitives
and then a second adapter for Google
primitives the rain make it rain maker
API is all stayed exactly the same so
all of our automated tooling stayed the
same
then we updated the Rainmaker a you I
added Belgium as an option because the
Frankfurt data center didn't exist at
that time and bam we had Google our
second fear was the network connection
between AWS and Google since our data
was now going to be crossing the
Atlantic so we used the standard cloud
provider VPNs to connect the two
networks together across the ocean and
it was giving us approximately one
gigabit per second and taking time to
ramp up to that speed to support HBase
replication and our Kafka streams we
wanted to make sure we could get 10
gigabits per second throughput across
the ocean and we wanted to treat our
European data center just like any other
availability zone within Amazon so the
way that our team did that was actually
rather clever they noticed that they
would get a 6 millisecond and 6
milliseconds of latency between our data
center in Virginia and Google's data
center in Virginia so we set up
strongswan which is an open source VPN
tunnel to connect the Virginia data
centers once the traffic was inside
Google across the Atlantic on Google's
fast internal network instead of over
the open Internet and we were able to
get the performance that we needed the
final thing that we feared were live
migrations and we really feared them
live migrations are actually very clever
when Google needs to replace hardware or
update their hypervisor they move your
VM from one piece of hardware to another
behind-the-scene when we first heard
about this we thought it was really cool
but then we were afraid of what it was
going to do to HBase
so with HBase we keep a strict 6
millisecond response time and this is
important because the HubSpot UI touches
many different services and those
services touch many other services so
any delay in any request can cause a
cascading effect resulting in a slow UI
for our users so even though the
difference between a 6 millisecond
response time and a 10 millisecond
response time doesn't seem like much
that makes a difference between a slow
and snappy
you I for our customers so the way live
migrations work is Google takes a
snapshot of your VM and starts an
identical copy on other hardware then
they pause the original VM copy over
anything that changed and then start up
the new VM the Google folks told us that
this could take up to a second depending
on how much RAM was on the original VM
or how heavy the RAM turn was HBase is
very right intensive meaning the pause
time could end up being very long and
that could be a catastrophic to the
response time so to solve this we spun
up an HBase cluster in Google we
replayed production workloads through
that cluster had the Google engineers
force a bunch of live migrations and we
watched our graphs to see the effects we
were shocked to see there were no
effects at all so at that point our
three fears were gone so we committed to
moving forward with Google in the EU so
now that our fears were gone what was
the plan this was four steps update rain
maker spin up the platform components
work out all the application dependency
issues and finally update our DNS to
send traffic to the EU so it took us
five days to update it took us five days
to set up our infrastructure to deploy
to Frankfurt we had to move from Belgium
to Frankfurt this involves setting up
DNS services as well as puppet rainmaker
was also really easy to set up because
we already had the adapter for Google so
it was simply pointing to a new region
next was the bulk of the work where we
considered HubSpot really multi cloud
and multi region our team spun up the
clusters we needed to run our platform
in Google including zookeeper HBase LDAP
vault we had originally hacked a deploy
option to Belgium early on to get a
proof of concept for Orion to deploy to
Google in the EU
so we rewrote it the right way and
deployed analytics as our first test
service we also got the product
engineering teams excited and showed
them the simple way
could configure their services to run in
both regions or just one or the other so
they stood started deploying at that
time to this took us 30 days to get
right product teams started untangling
their application services at that time
they figured out what they needed to run
to support our data collection services
in the EU independently without reaching
back to the US we had quite a few to
work through at that time and plenty of
skeletons in the closet
apart from spinning up clusters and
deploying services there was actually an
even bigger hurdle and this was the
human element of the project we have
more than 60 small autonomous
engineering teams they are in Dublin
Boston as well as remote teams with so
many micro services we need to figure
out the dependencies and uncover all of
those skeletons as fast as possible so
this was the key question how do you get
everyone to find all of the skeletons so
with the way we did this was with a
month and a half of weekly chaos testing
we decided this was the best way to get
everyone on the same page to figure out
what we didn't know about and to move
fast together so we got an engineer from
each product team who owned the
collection service along with the
platform engineers we bought them all
lunch we dialed in the Dublin team and
we broke the network so that first test
they were all very confident that
everything was going to work but there
was a huge list of things that broke our
goal was to cut the network and be able
to restart all of those services and
ensure that they could survive
completely independently so we made a
list and it was a very long list of
everything that we had broken and all of
the misc dependencies for example
databases that were still running in the
u.s. that needed to be replicated
authentication services domain services
as well so we added those teams to
future tests and the list of what we
needed to fix was long but the teams all
agreed to fix them and come back the
next week so
did this each week for six weeks and
each week the list got shorter and
shorter until there was no more list so
we even came up with some creative ways
to cause failures between the two data
centers and tried those as well until
finally it was all green and we were
confident we could run in the EU data
center completely independent from the
US the final step was to enable
CloudFlare geo debase dns for our
production traffic that took a few days
to roll out because we did each service
one at a time to make sure that there
were no disruptions to our customers so
the overall timeline was in fact longer
than the 30 days I promised in the title
of this talk but we were officially
multi-cloud and multi-region with our
platform and one test service but just
not fully production ready in 30 days
but a short seven weeks later we met our
deadline with room to spare so what was
the result today nine percent of our VMs
are running in Google Cloud we saw a 5x
speed-up in response time for our
European customers due to SSL
terminating in Europe and 17 percent of
our collection requests now are
processed on Google cloud the EU is also
spared to service disruptions when there
were Network issues as well one funny
thing that happened during our testing
was a trans-pacific network cut during
our tests so requests from Australia
we're getting routed to Europe instead
of the US so we were getting a similar
unexpected boost for our customers in
Australia at the same time so at the end
of q1 we celebrated and the team has
moved on to their next big mission after
some great lessons learned about going
multi region and multi-cloud at the same
time so let's recap those key takeaways
list and test your fears first and do
this fast
keep it simple do not bite off more than
you can chew with the first go there
will be plenty of unknowns use chaos
testing as your best friend it is a
great forcing function to
uncover those skeletons and shed light
on what is not done treat your
infrastructure as code use abstractions
to be able to experiment and move fast
and finally don't forget to use lunch to
coerce the human side of the project
thank you
[Music]